When I originally planned my trip to Israel,...
...I thought I would focus the majority of my travels...
...on the religious and cultural sites.
However, upon arrival, I was blown away by Israel's flourishing culinary scene.
Much of the Israeli diet is vegetarian-based,...
...but it's so tasty that you'll forget there's no meat.
Thank you so much.
So, I'm walking around Carmel Market and I came across this stand that sells druze.
It's kind of like a Israeli crepe that has a lot of salty goodness inside.
Druze.
Traditionally served with homemade cheese made from yogurt,...
...drizzled with olive oil, za'atar and rolled in the crepe-thin pita,...
...this dish is delicious to eat freshly made.
I've never had it, so this is going to be my first bite.
That's creamy.
I highly recommend coming out to Carmel Market and checking out the foods they have.
You can see them prepared right in front of your eyes.
Sabich.
This Jewish-Iraqi delicacy is a heavenly mixture of fried eggplant, hard-boiled eggs,...
...green onions, tomatoes, parsley, tahini; the list could go on.
Oh, yeah!
This is sabich.
It comes in two forms: with pita or with normal sandwich bread.
This is one of my favorite Israeli foods.
It is a vegetarian masterpiece and one that should not be missed here in Israel.
All right, we're at dinner now.
We got two hummuses here.
We got hummus with artichoke and we've got hummus with mushroom,...
...but that's not the specialty tonight.
The specialty is malabi.
On my last night in Israel, I was introduced to malabi, a cream-based dessert...
...flavored with rose water and topped with pistachios.
Oh man, that's good!
You can actually taste the rose water inside of it.
It's like nothing I've ever tasted before.